You just a created a look up relationship. You already
created a master detail relationship before. What's the difference? In a
master detail, the child record needs to have a parent. It
wouldn't make sense to have an attendee without a festival. If
we were to think about the relationship between attendees and festivals,
we could delete an attendee and the festival would be fine.
But if we deleted a festival, all of the attendees would
have to go away too. And that's called a cascade delete.
Look up relationships don't have cascade deletes. So if we
were to delete a stage, we wouldn't necessarily want to
get rid of all those bands, because those bands are
still around and they could play at a different stage.